bien alors mes chers collègues nous
entendons à présent monsieur
Jean-Christophe conck et ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées sur la feuille de
route de son ministère dont le plfs16
pour 2023 qui a été présenté sur lundi
en conseil des ministres et qui
constitue la première étape de cette
feuille de route j'indique que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo qui sera retransmise en direct sur
le site du Sénat et disponible en vidéo
à la demande monsieur le ministre je
vais vous laisser la parole pour une
présentation luminaire avant de donner
la parole au commissaire qui souhaite
vous interroger je ne doute pas que les
questions seront nombreuses et notamment
celle de notre rapporteur de la branche
concernée Philippe mouillé monsieur le
ministre
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les membres du bureau mesdames et
Mesdames messenatrices Messieurs les
sénateur bonjour écoutez je suis ravi
d'être là devant vous aujourd'hui je
sais que vous avez une journée chargée
donc je vais essayer d'être le plus
clair et le plus direct possible dans ma
dans ma présentation
je vous remercie de votre de votre
accueil et évidemment mon cabinet
moi-même nous tenons à votre disposition
pour des échanges directs à l'avenir
autant que de que de besoin pour parler
de sujets tant nationaux que locaux vous
savez que j'étais avant d'être ministre
directeur général de la Croix-Rouge
française et que à ce titre je sais
combien il est important de rester
connecté avec les réalités de terrain
donc cette audition doit me permettre à
la fois de vous présenter dans les
grandes lignes la feuille de route qui
m'a été confiée par la première ministre
et en même temps de vous présenter les
grandes lignes du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale donc
j'ai injecté dans cette dans cette
présentation de la feuille de route les
premières mesures que vous trouverez
dans ce dans ce texte le ministère dont
j'ai la responsabilité et le ministère
des solidarités
concrètes et donc j'ai pour but dans la
mission qui m'a été confiée de pouvoir
apporter des réponses très
opérationnelles aux problématiques que
se posent aujourd'hui les les Français
construire avec vous des solutions je
crois vraiment dans la force de la
co-construction avec le Parlement avec
les collectivités avec les acteurs sur
les territoires sur les associations les
entreprises les entrepreneurs sociaux et
puis les personnes accompagnées
elles-mêmes puisque je crois on a un
vrai enjeu de pouvoir
intégrer dans l'élaboration de nos
politiques publiques des des phases très
amont ces personnes accompagnées c'est
aussi le ministère le ministère de
toutes les vulnérabilités du premier au
dernier jour de nos vies comme j'ai
l'habitude de le dire et je souhaite par
ce par cette approche que nous
dépassions l'approche silotée qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui dans le portage des
politiques de solidarité et parce que
bien évidemment une personne comme ces
problématiques ne se divisent pas qu'on
puisse les accompagner de façon globale
l'ensemble des chantiers que je vais
porter doivent répondre à un triple
objectif mais aussi à une double
urgence le premier de ces objectifs
c'est d'adapter notre système au besoin
sociaux d'aujourd'hui que ce soit les
familles monoparentales que ce soit la
grande pauvreté que ce soit le
vieillissement de la population le
deuxième objectif est celui de réduire
les inégalités de destin et à commencer
évidemment des dès la naissance mais
aussi tout au long de la vie pour aller
vers une société qui soit réellement
inclusive et puis enfin le troisième
objectif c'est celui de contribuer à la
société du plein emploi je crois pas
qu'il y ait d'un côté l'économie et puis
de l'autre l'état social je crois que
les deux fonctionnent ensemble c'est
parce que là fonctionne que l'autre peut
être performant et c'est parce que l'un
est performant que l'autre peut-être
financé
et je précise d'ailleurs que le secteur
social et médico-social et dans notre
pays le quatrième secteur pourvoyeur
d'emploi ce qui doit nous donner on va
dire une
ce qui est un argument supplémentaire
pour travailler à la question de
l'attractivité des métiers dans le dans
le secteur la double urgence dont je
parlais c'est d'abord l'urgence du
quotidien c'est comment on protège nos
concitoyens les plus vulnérables face
aux crises qu'elles soient climatique
qu'elle soit sociale qu'elle soit
économique et de ce point de vue on a
déjà répondu dans cette temporalité très
rapidement dès cet été avec la location
exceptionnelle de solidarité qui a été
votée qui a été distribué le 15
septembre dernier après de 11 millions
de familles à toutes les mesures
inscrites dans ce PLFSS de soutien aussi
aux acteurs du médico-social il y a une
grosse attente de la part de ses acteurs
d'être protégés dans cette situation et
puis c'est plus généralement les qu'on
doit accompagner face aux événements
climatiques canicules hiver avec le plan
grand froid notamment et puis la
deuxième
urgence c'est celle d'anticiper et
d'accompagner la population dans les
grandes transitions démographiques
écologiques et solidaire donc vous
l'avez compris le périmètre de mon
ministère il va couvrir tous les âges de
la vie avec aux deux bouts la question
de la petite enfance et de l'autre le
grand âge et en continu la question de
la performance de notre modèle de
protection sociale et de l'inclusivité
de notre société concernant le premier
bout de la vie à savoir le la question
du bien grandir ce qu'on porte
aujourd'hui c'est un soutien clair et
fort aux familles dans la poursuite du
travail initié notamment par mon
prédécesseur Adrien taquet dans la
politique des 1000 premiers jours sur
l'ensemble du territoire qu'on souhaite
poursuivre et amplifier la priorité de
soutien en famille elle se traduit
directement dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale avec
une hausse du budget de la branche
famille et de près d'un milliard 600
millions d'euros avec deux objectifs le
premier de favoriser l'égalité
professionnelle entre les hommes et les
femmes et de contribuer à la société du
plein emploi en développement l'accès à
un mode de garde pour les jeunes enfants
et le second de continuer à lutter
contre les inégalités de destin on
intervenant dès la petite enfance et en
soutenant les familles les plus fragiles
concrètement
ça se passe avec la réforme du
complément mode de garde d'une part avec
la révision de son barème pour permettre
aux familles qui n'ont pas de place en
crèche de pouvoir faire garder leur
enfant au même coup par une assistante
maternelle ou une garde à domicile et
puis la seconde mesure c'est
l'allongement du bénéfice du complément
mode de garde pour les enfants de 6 à 12
ans pour les familles monoparentales
comme vous le savez les familles
monoparentales sont à 90% d'entre elles
des femmes qui pour 30% d'entre elles
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté et donc
c'est une mesure qui devrait permettre
d'abaisser le taux de pauvreté de ces
familles de plus de de plus de deux
points concrètement en passant
en passant également en augmentant de 50
% la
pension alimentaire minimale donc la
location de soutien familial qui passera
de 123 à 185 euros par mois et par
enfant
la réforme du complément mode de garde
s'ajoute aussi au lancement de la
trajectoire qui nous permettra à terme
de créer 200000 places d'accueil du
jeune enfant d'ici à 2030 c'est un
véritable enjeu pour les 160 000 parents
qui aujourd'hui ne reprennent pas de
travail faute de fautes de solution ces
mesures sont quelque part la première
pierre de du service public de la petite
enfance que le Président de la
République souhaite que nous mettions en
oeuvre à construire évidemment avec les
collectivités en particulier le blog
communal et puis l'ensemble des acteurs
du secteur autour de trois priorités
plus de solutions de qualité plus
d'égalité d'accès sur le plan financier
sur le territoire pour répondre à des
inégalités sociales et territoriales et
puis des réponses à la pénurie de
personnel enfin soutenir les familles
c'est aussi soutenir la parentalité et
la conjugalité mieux prévenir les
conflits intra-famidiaux et les ruptures
de liens familiaux c'est dans l'intérêt
des enfants c'est l'intérêt des parents
notamment des femmes mais aussi de la
collectivité dans son dans son ensemble
à l'autre bout de la vie il y a la
question du Bien vieillir
l'urgence d'un secteur en crise de
confiance qui est à la fois confronté à
l'impact de l'inflation de la flambée
des prix de l'énergie et du manque de
personnel tu as déjà mis un certain
nombre de mesures en place pour
restaurer la confiance dans les EHPAD et
soutenir leur transformation toutes les
mesures qui ont été
incluses dans la loi de financement la
sécurité sociale pour 2022 et tout ce
qui a fait Brigitte bourguignon au
premier semestre
2022 et puisqu'on continuera à mettre
dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 pour
compenser donc également l'impact de
l'inflation avec l'extension du gel
tarifaire de l'énergie à l'ensemble des
EHPAD
les revalorisations salariales donc dans
la continuité du Ségur mais j'ai annoncé
également l'augmentation du point
d'indice de la fonction publique qui
sera étendu à l'ensemble du secteur et
donc aux établissements privés
ce qu'on doit également travailler et là
nous allons travailler dans le cadre du
Conseil national de la refondation c'est
que le Président de la République a
souhaité se porter ce sujet de la
transition démographique dans le cadre
du CNR autour de trois axes prioritaires
le premier celui de la prévention pour
retarder la perte d'autonomie et
personne aux personnes et permettre aux
personnes âgées de vivre dans la cité
comme elle le souhaite on va faire le
choix du domicile puisque c'est aussi le
choix des français ce qui se traduit
déjà dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale avec
la création de nouvelles places de
services de soins infirmiers à domicile
la mise en place d'une tarification qui
prenne mieux en compte le profil des
bénéficiaires un tarif plancher qui sera
revalorisé cette année pour tenir compte
de l'inflation et le financement des
deux heures annoncées supplémentaires
chaque semaine auprès des 780 000
personnes qui bénéficient de
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie à
domicile donc des heures dédiées à la
convivialité à la prévention mais qui
permettront aussi d'améliorer les
conditions de travail l'organisation du
travail des intervenants à domicile qui
subissent trop souvent des temps
partiels ou des temps fractionnés
au-delà du PLFSS
le bien vivre le Bien vieillir à
domicile c'est aussi l'adaptation des
logements et donc on travaille dès
maintenant à pouvoir se mettre en ordre
de marche pour déployer ma prime adapte
pour pouvoir adapter les logements à
partir de 2024 et pour permettre
l'adaptation d'au moins 400 000
logements d'ici à 2027
la question ensuite de la citoyenneté et
du lien social pour garantir la
participation des personnes âgées à la
société à la vie de la société à
l'élaboration des politiques publiques
aussi dans toute leur dimension d'une
société aussi qui se mobilise pour
lutter contre l'isolement social qui a
un véritable fléau pour pour nous aînés
et puis la dernière priorité c'est la
question des métiers qui se limite pas à
la question de la rémunération qui doit
toucher l'ensemble des dimensions qui
font l'attractivité que soit la qualité
de vie au travail que ce soit la
formation les parcours professionnels
les transitions professionnelles la
valorisation des acquis d'expérience
donc vous avez dû d'ores et déjà parler
aujourd'hui et qui passe aussi par des
mesures d'urgence notamment celles qui
consiste à s'engager dans le financement
à terme de 50 000 nouveaux postes dans
dans les EHPAD on en a inscrit un
certain nombre de cette année dans le
PLFSS malgré les difficultés de
recrutement que connaît le secteur pour
montrer aussi un engagement volontariste
sur cette sur cette dynamique
sur évidemment j'ai entendu il y a
beaucoup de débats qui se concentre
autour de la question loi grand âge
Palois Palois grand âge ma réponse est
assez claire c'est que avant de parler
du contenant il faut qu'on parle
ensemble du du contenu j'ai dit il y a
une triple temporalité pour moi une
temporalité immédiate il y aura des
mesures dans le dans le plfs pour
répondre aux problématiques aujourd'hui
aux urgences que connaissent que connaît
le secteur médico-social on poursuit
dans une seconde temporalité la
transformation notamment du secteur du
grand âge avec le virage de missilière
et la transformation modernisation de
nos EHPAD et puis on portera une
ambition dans le cadre du Conseil
national de la refondation qui pourrait
le fait aboutir le cas échéant à des
mesures législatives mais post
conclusion au printemps 2023
une petite parenthèse enfin pour finir
sur sur le grand âge concernant la fin
de vie et l'articulation entre grand âge
et fin de vie parce que j'étais aussi
beaucoup interrogé là dessus parfois de
façon un peu un peu hasardeuse mais
sache que je voulais passer c'était que
quelques soient la boutissement de ces
de ces discussions évidemment elle ne
doit pas être le symbole de l'échec
d'une société qui ne saurait pas prendre
soin et accompagner les plus les plus
vulnérables les personnes vulnérables ne
sont pas un poids pour notre société
mais au contraire une richesse et c'est
ce que je souhaite porter en tant que
ministre de toute les vulnérabilités je
participerai moi-même pleinement au
débat sur la fin de vie tout en bien
évidemment
travaillant sur ces deux sujets de façon
bien distinguées parce que le sujet de
la fin de vie est un sujet qui porte
aussi bien sur des dimensions
personnelles qu'un team mais aussi
familial et collective qui touchent au
regard que nous portons sur la fragilité
de façon générale sur la mort sur la
souffrance et sur la liberté qui touche
aussi au rôle des soignants et à celui
des proches et puis qui nous devra nous
permettre aussi d'écouter la parole des
tout premiers concernés des personnes en
fin de vie des familles et aider
soignants concernant les préoccupations
transverses celle de la mission qui m'y
confiait de transformer notre modèle de
protection sociale en partant peut-être
d'objectifs partagés pour un système qui
soit plus performant plus juste et plus
orienté aussi vers l'insertion des
personnes vous savez que notre système
aujourd'hui de de prestation sociale et
complexe il favorise la défiance par son
innisibilité le non recours la fraude
aussi bien qu'il soit
l'un des plus performants des pays de de
l'OCDE je crois qu'on a là aussi un
travail à faire pour le moderniser et le
rendre plus performant ce modèle on a
essayé aussi de d'y apporter des
réponses
urgentes par rapport à la situation des
personnes que nous accompagnons
notamment cet été avec la revalorisation
des des minima sociaux et l'aide
d'exceptionnels de solidarité dont j'ai
parlé en introduction on portera ce
projet de modernisation qui s'appelle
solidarité à la source voilà de façon
beaucoup plus structurelle pour
simplifier le système et pouvoir
adresser les aides à ceux qui en ont
réellement besoin et les inscrire dans
un vrai parcours de d'insertion et
d'accompagnement
on travaillera aussi d'ici à la fin de
l'année dans le cadre de ma feuille de
route au renouvellement de la stratégie
de lutte contre la pauvreté donc j'ai
déjà réuni les acteurs du secteur la
semaine dernière commencé les
consultations aussi avec les avec les
collectivités et la première ministre
m'a demandé d'aboutir à se
renouvellement d'impact de solidarité
entre l'État les collectivités et les
acteurs de la solidarité d'ici à la fin
de cette année
trop objectif celui de réussir la
transition écologique et solidaire je
crois que on a un enjeu collectif fort
d'accompagner les personnes les plus
vulnérables dans ces grandes transitions
on regarde notamment bien de l'impact
sur les personnes les plus vulnérables
notamment des changements climatiques
par exemple et on le fera en ayant à
coeur pour réduire la pauvreté dans
notre pays de travailler sur les trois
principaux postes de dépenses
contraintes des ménages à savoir le
logement avec la lutte contre la
précarité énergétique et la rénovation
n'est pas sur thermique la mobilité là
aussi il y a un enjeu de déploiement à
grande échelle des solutions solidaires
et puis l'alimentation enfin avec des
cette année le doublement des crédits
pour l'aide alimentaire qui a été permis
dans le cadre des discussions
parlementaires sur le projet de loi de
finance rectificative
et puis à plus long terme voilà pour
pour travailler sur les suites du chèque
alimentaire l'accès inalimentation saine
durable et équilibrée pour toutes les
personnes précaires et aussi lutter
contre la question de l'obésité qui
touche aujourd'hui 17 % de nos enfants
le handicap évidemment avant de terminer
je veux dire quand même quelques mots
même si je crois que vous auditionnerez
également Geneviève darrieussec vous
verrez que le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
respecte rigoureusement les engagements
qui ont été pris notamment à l'issue de
la dernière conférence nationale du du
handicap là aussi il y a un
investissement financier c'est 700
millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaire qui vont être consacrés
toujours au développement de l'offre
médico-sociale à la détection précoce et
à l'accompagnement des troubles du
spectre autistique du polyhandicap ou
encore des personnes âgées
vieillissantes moi aussi me tâcher de
développ le l'articulation entre l'école
et le secteur médico-social dans un acte
2 de l'école inclusive et un
renouvellement aussi de la stratégie
autiste mais trouble du
neuro-développement qui doit s'achever à
la fin de cette année évidemment tout ça
s'inscrira dans l'habitude de
concertation que nous avons organisé
avec le secteur et les personnes
concernées avec un comité
interministériel qui doit se tenir début
octobre pour préparer une grande
conférence du handicap en février 2023
en conclusion je voudrais aborder deux
sujets transverses qui sont
indispensables
pour pouvoir conduire cette feuille de
route la première ce sont les richesses
la richesse humaine c'est-à-dire les
femmes et les hommes qui s'engagent pour
transformer et mettre en oeuvre la
transformation de ces politiques
publiques c'est une un sujet qui
transcende l'ensemble des politiques
publiques dont j'ai la responsabilité de
la petite enfance au grand âge en
passant par le handicap ou la lutte
contre les exclusions on a une crise
aujourd'hui un des vocations des
difficultés de recrutement et
d'attractivité dans le secteur et donc
ce sera vraiment une question
transversale que nous porterons de façon
interministérielle on l'a fait sans
doute de façon trop stylotée et
cloisonné jusqu'à présent et donc on va
essayer d'avoir une approche plus
transversale plus globale de sortir
aussi de la logique Ségure de la santé
pour repasser dans une dynamique qui
soit plus pérenne et plus structurel de
de ces questions et la deuxième c'est la
confiance indispensable dans notre
système fragiliser par la fraude mais
aussi par la question de la maltraitance
qui est sans doute un sujet majeur qui
est trop longtemps été mis sous le tapis
et sur lequel nous nous agissons j'ai
annoncé la semaine dernière dernière
plusieurs saisines la saisine du Haut
conseil de santé publique pour pouvoir
faire une analyse des données
scientifiques et améliorer le recueil de
ces cas de maltraitance une saisine une
seconde saisine de la Conférence
nationale de santé pour construire la
contribution des partis prenantes au
traitement territorial des alertes de
maltraitance et enfin une saisine de
ligase avec mes collègues Braun et cobel
sur les systèmes d'information et leur
mise en cohérence pour une meilleure
visibilité de toutes les alertes de
maltraitance c'est saisine elles vont
pas évidemment épuiser le sujet sur
lequel une grande stratégie sera
décidé d'ici la fin de l'année voilà et
donc j'aurai également à coeur de rendre
régulièrement des comptes sur l'avancée
de cette feuille de route et surtout sur
la mesure de son impact je pense que
c'est un élément important aussi de la
crédibilité de nos politiques publiques
merci monsieur le ministre et bon
courage pour cette fille de route
ambitieuse je fais passer tout de suite
la parole à Philip mouillé qui rapporte
merci pour ces précisions j'ai quelques
questions complémentaires et de demande
de précision la première est un élément
d'actualité vous voulez pas évoqué mais
ça concernait décongélisation de la
location à dudicapée un décret est
annoncé pour la mi-décembre est-ce que
vous pouvez nous le confirmer surtout
qu'on nous indique que rien ne se
passera tant que le décret ne sera pas
aujourd'hui sortie et donc comme l'enjeu
du calendrier était un enjeu fondamental
plus vous attendez pour le décret plus
nous retarderons la capacité à mettre en
place cette réforme donc pour venir
concrètement où est-ce qu'on est la mise
en oeuvre de la décongélisation tant
attendue
deuxième point ça concerne vous l'avez
évoqué très très rapidement dans les
mesures handicap la rentrée scolaire a
lieu il y a quelques semaines conformant
aux engagements pris par le gouvernement
de nouveaux postes de aesh ont été créés
mais en même temps nous voyons une
désorganisation importante sur tout a
été un national des besoins qui
aujourd'hui sont ne sont pas pourvus et
donc des familles qui sont dans
l'attente et que pensez-vous faire pour
réorganiser et remettre ta place cette
situation qui n'est pas qu'un enjeu
financier qui est aussi un moyen un
enjeu d'attractivité du métier
d'organisation et là je pense qu'il y a
urgence étant donné le calendrier
troisième point vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de l'automatisation du versement
la source des prestations sociales pour
la lutte contre le non-rocourt est-ce
que vous pouvez vous avez rappelé le
contour mais quel est le calendrier et
surtout comment c'est financé puisque
automatiquement le recours entraîne des
dépenses supplémentaires
autre point qui est dans le dans le
pdfss donc c'est le débat concernant les
contrôles les contrôles pouvez-vous
confirmer que cette évolution permettra
d'étendre le contrôle concernant les
EHPAD à l'ensemble des groupes et pas ce
plan aux établissements et dans la
foulée j'ouvrais donc préciser
concernant le dossier hors pa puisque
les enjeux qui ont été définis par les
gaz l'IGF font par les fonds fixe le
montant à récupérer à 56 millions
d'euros alors Corea lui a décidé qu'il
ne donnerait pas cette somme là donc
concrètement comment vous souhaitez vous
comment allez-vous procéder par rapport
à cette démarche là et puis de dernier
point plus générale vous avez évoqué un
calendrier en disant voilà nous avons la
concentration grand âge qui va arriver
en début d'année la Conférence nationale
du handicap on doit l'articuler avec le
pdfss que nous avons voté maintenant un
calendrier dans l'attente d'une loi
éventuellement grand âge comment ces
article tout ça parce que aujourd'hui
nous avons appelé FS16 qui donne des
moyens supplémentaires
principalement sur voler grand âge qui
est une continuité finalement on
continue à mettre des montants sur une
politique qui est organisée de la même
façon le monde du handicap est plutôt
assez mécontent aujourd'hui sont
d'ailleurs dans la rue aujourd'hui une
partie de territoire national considère
que les moyens financiers ne sont pas là
et qui a pas de réformes et c'est une
continuité un minima des engagements du
du du Queen mystériel donc la grande
question aujourd'hui comment vous voyez
les évolutions parce que il y a des
revues sur les structures exposé sur le
personnel il y a des enjeux sur
l'attractivité des métiers 700 millions
d'euros que vous devez gérer les 100
départements l'enjeu sur l'inclusion
scolaire l'évolution sur l'autisme
grosso modo il y a pas grand chose donc
aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on se situe au
regard des enjeux globaux et au regard
surtout des annonces qui étaient faites
au moment de l'élection présidentielle
et puis je t'aimerai par une petite clin
d'oeil et quelques semaines vous étiez
de l'autre côté de la barrière vous
souhaitiez très fortement qu'on avance
sur le volet grand âge et l'eau de
l'autonomie j'entends votre calendrier
est-ce que le printemps 2023 sera tenu
si vous voulez bien monsieur le ministre
je vais passer la parole Olivier Hainaut
qui le rapporteur de la branche famille
pour répondre aux deux rapporteurs et
ensuite on prendra des questions des
collègues merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour vos
propos alors concernant la branche
famille laquelle est
excédentaire chaque année quelques
questions oui cette c'est c'est pas
nouveau
concernant le service public accueille
jeune enfant
parce que je pense que c'est une
question clé de notre société vous
l'avez relevé ça a été un débat lors de
l'élection présidentielle d'ailleurs que
ce soit sur la question de la natalité
c'est un frein à beaucoup de pour
beaucoup de couples ou pour beaucoup de
femmes cette question du service public
de de l'accueil jeune enfant la question
du renouvellement des générations et
faut pas qu'on marche dans les pas du
Japon par exemple je lisais entendez
dans une audition et que Frédéric que le
Japon de voir accueillir 21 millions de
personnes parce que il y a un manque de
bras compte tenu d'une baisse de la
natalité qui est beaucoup plus ancienne
pour le le Japon et puis si on fait la
transition avec le débat de tout à
l'heure les tensions sur l'emploi et le
retour à l'emploi des allocataires du
RSA notamment un certain nombre de de
foyers monoparentaux de femmes seules
souvent la question de la gare de
l'enfant revient sur le le frein à
l'emploi c'est un des principes
principaux freins à l'emploi ça revient
toujours donc ma question concerne le le
financement votre volonté la complexité
aussi entre la PSU la page la prestation
d'accueil aux jeunes enfants
il y a évidemment vous avez aussi parlé
de la maltraitance et de ce qui s'était
passé dans dans une crèche lyonnaise il
y a un équilibre à trouver entre les
financements la qualité les objectifs
quantitatif faire en sorte qu'on puisse
se retrouver le souffle parce qu'on au
fond le souffle des années 2000 pour ce
qui concerne la création de place en
crèche il ait été un peu il est perdu au
niveau de l'État mais aussi au niveau du
bloc communal pour des questions des
raisons financières mais il y a plus la
même dynamique que celle qu'on a pu
connaître alors même que les besoins
sont toujours là et donc c'est une
question centrale pour notre société
pour notre pays et donc vous vous
interrogez aussi sur votre volonté
d'associer le Parlement sur cette
question puisqu'il y avait une amorce de
réforme sur la précédente législature
mais ça avait été adopté par ordonnance
donc vous entendre aussi sur sur cette
question et enfin sur le complément
libre choix de mode de garde ça concerne
le PLFSS on a le l'occasion de d'en
parler je voyais d'ailleurs madame
Humbert qui faillit qui feuillette les
pages c'est ça les bons élèves ils ont
toujours les bons documents au moment où
il faut
et et donc évoquer cette question de la
réforme du calcul de la du du CMG et et
de voir si vous avez déjà étudié les
impacts de cette réforme et des familles
qui pourraient être perdants de gagnante
et d'éventuelles compensation je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
merci alors je vais essayer de répondre
aux questions de Monsieur mouiller dans
dans l'ordre la hache vous confirme que
le décret sera signé au plus tard au
mois de décembre je fais tout pour qu'il
le soit avant et on n'a pas attendu de
de le décret pour commencer à travailler
avec la CNAF pour tenir les délais et le
cas échéant des délais plus courts mais
je me suis engagé à ce que octobre 2023
soit vraiment la date la date limite
donc on fait tout ce qu'on peut
concernant la rentrée scolaire vous avez
raison de dire que
le nombre de postes
à une nouvelle fois augmenté c'est plus
4000 postes d'avsh on est arrivé à 125
430 000 enfants qui sont scolarisés
effectivement il reste des besoins qui
sont non couverts et chaque situation
individuelle de besoin non couvert est
un drame à lui seul on a mis en place
pour cette rentrée un
canal de de communication avec les
familles pour pouvoir suivre justement
chaque famille qui n'avait pas de de
solution et essayer d'en trouver avec
elle et
dans une perspective de plus long terme
je l'ai dit la première ministre s'est
engagé à ce que cette question de
l'école inclusive face l'objet d'une
nouvelle dynamique et dans un acte 2 en
fait de l'école inclusive et donc sera
discuté dans le cas de la conférence
naturelle du handicap de février 2023 à
la fois pour regarder si les ressources
aujourd'hui sont suffisantes pour
continuer à accompagner les enfants en
situation de handicap il y a des
scolariser si et c'est difficile
aujourd'hui on arrive à enclencher le
pas d'une école qui soit vraiment
inclusive c'est-à-dire aussi de faire
rentrer le médico-social
à l'éducation nationale et puis
peut-être d'évaluer aussi les
dispositifs d'accompagnement
voilà savoir si aujourd'hui les
prescriptions correspondent aussi
réellement aux besoins des enfants et si
on peut pas
faire un peu évoluer le système donc
tout ça sera revu dans le cadre de cette
réflexion sur
la question de la solidarité à la source
c'est un projet de
quinquennat si on veut aller jusqu'au
bout en sachant que donc aujourd'hui on
est en train de regarder
au contour en fait du du
projet les études qui avaient été faites
par l'adresse par Monsieur Langlard à
l'époque des réflexions autour du revenu
universel d'activité donc pas du tout la
voix qu'on souhaite aujourd'hui
emprunter couvrait l'ensemble du du
système aujourd'hui on se dit que pour
lancer les choses on pourrait être sur
un panier de prestation qui soit plus
plus ramassé
à elle seule RSA prime d'activité et
aide au logement recouvre à peu près 90%
des bénéficiaires des prestations
sociales dans notre pays 40 mill
milliard d'euros sur les 60 milliards
qui sont
distribués donc ça sera à peu près le
périmètre et un projet en plusieurs
étapes dont la première étape pourrait
être celle de la simplification du
pré-remplissage des
des formulaires de demande de prestation
avec un travail sur la lutte contre le
non recours et le aller vers travail
aussi qui nous permettrait dès cette
première étape de lutter contre la
fraude puisque l'idée ce serait vraiment
de sécuriser en fait le renseignement
des des de ces formulaires de demande de
prestation et donc d'avoir vraiment une
sécurisation des droits de ces de ces
personnes
concernant les contrôles donc je vous
confirme que les mesures qui sont
incluses dans le PLFSS vissent bien à
donner des moyens de contrôle des sièges
des groupes quel que soit la nature de
de ce groupe aux inspections voilà qui
faisait partie des mesures qui avaient
été proposées par le rapport bon et
meunier donc on a intégré dans le dans
le texte
concernant l'affaire hors pa
aujourd'hui des discussions sont en
cours avec entre la CNSA et ORPEA moi je
tiens à ce que l'État est une position
très ferme dans cette dans cette affaire
donc on est pas en train de discuter ou
de négocier on est en train de voilà ils
sont en train de d'expliquer aussi les
chiffres qui sont issus je le rappelle
des inspections
de nos corps d'inspection et donc voilà
un titre de recettes a été émis et on
compte bien récupérer les 56 millions
d'euros
exigés voilà
donc en tout cas encore une fois fermeté
du côté de l'État je l'ai dit on n'est
pas dans une dans une posture de
transaction
concernant l'articulation des différents
chantiers les choses sont bien les
choses sont bien coordonnées comme je
vous dis on a là un PLFSS d'urgence de
fin de cycle aussi structurel sur les
grandes politiques c'est vrai que on va
laisser le temps de la concertation sur
le handicap avec la préparation de la
future CNH sur le Bien vieillir avec le
CNR on devra bien croiser évidemment
les travaux pour avoir derrière une mise
en oeuvre ou des propositions concernant
l'autonomie de façon générale qui
recouvrera aussi
PA et enfin personne âgées et personne
en situation de handicap et donc voilà
pour aboutir aussi soit dans les textes
financiers de l'automne de l'automne
2023 soit dans des véhicules
juridique législatif ou réglementaire
qui resteront à déterminer à l'issue
c'est de ces réflexions mais on prend
vraiment le temps de la réflexion et oui
on aboutira sur le Bien vieillir ou plus
tard au printemps 2023 c'est l'objectif
qui m'a été fixé dans ma feuille de
route donc j'ai des comptes à rendre au
président de la République et à la
première ministre voilà concernant vos
questions monsieur Hainaut sur sur la
branche famille et notamment sur le
service public de la de la petite
enfance vous avez raison c'est un projet
de voilà avec une ambition majeure et
vraiment transformant pour pour la
société qui répond à un besoin qui est
au carrefour des politiques de natalité
de plein emploi d'égalité homme-femmes
puisque comme j'ai dit c'est souvent les
femmes qui sont malheureusement empêchés
dans leur travail pour pouvoir
accompagner leur
accompagner leur enfant
donc on a fait ses premières mesures
dans le PLFSS sur la réforme du
simplement un mode de garde et donc ils
sont financés la branche famille et
financée dans ce dans ce cadre là ça
devrait faire l'objet de négociation
aussi dans le cadre de la de la
renégociation de la convention
d'objectifs et de gestion de la CNAF qui
s'arrête à la fin de à la fin de cette
année on va ouvrir une concertation
cet automne avec à la fois les acteurs
de la petite enfance vous savez que j'ai
on a monté
un comité de filière donc pour traiter
notamment de la question de
l'attractivité mais plus largement la
question des professions de la petite
enfance ils seront mis à contribution
pour la création du service public de la
petite enfance et on doit ouvrir aussi
une concertation avec les collectivités
avec l'un des l'une des difficultés dans
la dynamique que vous avez décrite c'est
aussi une répartition de compétences qui
qui est très divisée entre l'État qui
finance via la branche famille entre les
un appartement qui contrôle et puis les
collectivités enfin les
communes et les intercommunalités qui
développent l'offre sur les territoires
qu'elles soient
public ou privé et donc on a une
discussion à avoir et on va mettre sur
la table la question pourquoi pas
donc c'est ouvert
de d'une compétence obligatoire pour le
bloc communal sur le développement de de
place pour d'accueil du jeune enfant
voilà donc c'est parti des sujets qu'on
discutera de toute façon très ouverte
avec les avec les collectivités ça fait
c'est ce qui a fait l'objet d'ailleurs
enfin moi j'invente rien c'est ce qui a
été proposé dans le cadre du rapport du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental sur sur cette question
voilà
et donc les financements seront vous
l'avez dit à la branche ami est une
branche qui est quand même dynamique et
qui permettra de financer le
développement progressif de ces
capacités d'accueil
très bien alors nous allons passer à
plusieurs sénateurs on va faire une
série une première série Xavier
la présidente monsieur le ministre la
part des familles monoparentales vous
l'avez rappelé et passer de 9,4% en 75 à
plus de 25% aujourd'hui et vous l'avez
rappelé dans 95 80 à 85% des cas ce sont
des femmes la mère qui élève seule un ou
plusieurs enfants il existe nous le
savons des fortes disparités entre les
familles dites traditionnelles et les
familles monoparentales sur au moins
deux plans tout d'abord sur le logement
puisque l'Insee rappelle que 37% de ses
enfants vivent dans un logement social
contre 15% pour les autres familles la
plupart de ces familles vivent dans un
logement dit surpeuplé où il manque au
moins une pièce
cette réalité a des conséquences
directes sur le développement et le
quotidien des enfants leur
épanouissement personnel et peut
également rendre difficile lorsque la
réalité puisque nous voyons et nous
l'avons vu notamment dans le confinement
dans de nombreux cases ne disposent pas
d'un endroit approprié pour étudier ou
faire leurs devoirs par ailleurs les
études récentes montrent que les enfants
de monoparentale sont deux fois plus
touchés par la pauvreté que l'ensemble
des enfants notre politique familiale a
tenté de répondre à cet enjeu depuis
plusieurs années mais il fallait un
engagement fort ciblant ces familles
face à ce constat alarmant vous avez
ainsi annoncé des mesures concrètes
conformément aux engagements du
Président de la République lors de la
campagne présidentielle sur les familles
monoparentales qui nous serons présentés
dans le cadre du pffss je pense
notamment à la révision de plusieurs
aides financières dont vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure concernant la garde
d'enfants et la revalorisation de la
location de soutien familial donc j'ai
trois questions qui ne sont pas
forcément toutes liées d'ailleurs au
fameux parentale
pourriez-vous nous préciser la nature de
ces révisions et l'impact concret sur
les familles qui trop souvent vivent
dans une situation de de précarité
extrême pouvez-vous nous donner
également le nombre de familles
concernées par ces dispositifs j'avais
cru comprendre qu'on était sur 2
millions de familles mais est-ce que
vous pouvez nous préciser ce chiffre une
autre question qui n'est pas ça sur la
question des numéros d'urgence
aujourd'hui nous avons le 119 pour
l'enfance en danger le 30 18 pour le
harcèlement
numérique le 30/20 sur les harcèlement
scolaires est-ce que vous pensez pas je
sais que c'est pas directement lié
uniquement à votre ministère mais est-ce
que nous vous ne pensez pas que nous
pourrions simplifier et avoir peut-être
des numéros d'urgence spécifiques à
l'enfance avec notamment derrière celui
qui fonctionne le mieux et qui est le
plus représentatif de l'enfance
notamment le 119 ma deuxième question et
ma troisième question concernant la
revalorisation du ce qu'on a appelé le
Ségur 3 des 183 euros pour le
Médico-Social notamment les traverses
sociaux est-ce qu'on a un premier bilan
de ce versement par les départements
parce que les certains retours me
laissent à penser que
tout le monde n'a pas forcément joué le
jeu
alors Daniel chassaint nous allons
prendre plusieurs questions ensuite
Abdallah Hassani et Laurence
monsieur le ministre donc je m'associe à
ce qui a été dit pour ce que vous avez
qualifié bien grandi j'ai ajouterai une
seule chose dans les rencontres que j'ai
fait avec les maires pendant l'été
beaucoup
regrettent si vous voulez le manque de
aesh je sais que ça a été augmenté mais
actuellement pour une inclusion il
manque de sachet elles sont pour
l'instant suffisamment payé
deux questions ce qui me concernent
d'abord les aides au département pour
concernant l'enfance les mecs c'est le
CDE et aussi pour appliquer le tout ça
pour appliquer le Ségur de la santé et
aussi au foyer occupationnel
et ma question vient sur le sur le Bien
Vieillir alors vous avez indiqué une
augmentation du nombre de Siad ça ça va
dans le bon sens et adapter bien sûr les
logements puisque les personnes âgées
souhaitent rester à domicile mais en ce
qui concerne les EHPAD vous avez indiqué
que le Président de la République allait
souhaité dans son programme créer 50 000
emplois c'est vrai qu'il est qu'il est
faut se fait ça fait cinq emplois en
gros par par EHPAD si on multiplie par
8000 + une augmentation du nombre d'epad
affaires parce que on va avoir une
augmentation très importante de la
dépendance on va passer d'un million
quatre à deux millions en me disant et
donc la question que je voulais vous
poser si vous voulez quand on aura le
l'application si vous voulez de la
cinquième branche d'assurance le
financement de la cinquième branche
d'Assurance Maladie pour prendre en
charge le plan grand âge et aussi qui
doit s'accompagner pour un plan massif
de création d'emploi d'aide-soignante et
aussi
d'infirmières voilà les deux questions
que je voulais poser merci
le ministre moi juste une question
comment cette feuille de route qui est
bien fournie
sera décliné dans les autres mères
juste ça
Laurence Cohen Laurence Cohen ensuite il
y aura elisabeton oui merci monsieur le
ministre pour vos propos introductifs
donc vous avez parlé de la loi grand âge
en disant que finalement il y aurait un
certain nombre de propositions qui se
feraient si j'ai bien compris via un
certain nombre d'amendements
c'est-à-dire que vous ne restez pas
l'arme au pied si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi mais permettez-moi Monsieur le
Ministre quand même de marquer mon
étonnement parce que la loi grand âge
c'est une arlésienne et on est on est
vraiment on est vraiment là face à un
problème de société c'est la conception
qu'on a quelle société on veut
construire pour vieillir ensemble et en
bonne santé le plus longtemps et ça ne
peut pas être à chaque fois remis remis
à deux à deux mains d'autant que moi je
le vois dans mon département le
département du Val-de-Marne la situation
de la filière gériatrique dans les
hôpitaux et dans les EHPAD et
catastrophiques et ça n'est pas
seulement la situation du Val-de-Marne
il y a une réduction du nombre de lits
des conditions de travail qui se
dégradent et je dois dire également une
mamie du privé avec sa vision lucrative
et on a vu combien ça pouvait faire de
dégâts alors effectivement vous annoncez
la création de 50000 emplois mais je
vous rappelle mais je pense que vous le
savez pertinemment que les besoins qui
sont et qui ont été évalués se situent à
000 emplois par an pendant trois ans et
il y a besoin non seulement de ses
emplois mais il y a besoin de formation
il y a besoin de salaire à la hauteur il
y a besoin de la reconnaissance de ses
professions parce que nous nous les
avons reçu au niveau de la commission
des affaires sociales nous pouvons avoir
des différences d'appréciations entre
nous mais nous avons quand même un socle
commun c'est d'entendre les souffrances
de ces personnels et elle nous disent ce
sont beaucoup de femmes que leur métier
n'est absolument pas reconnu et qu'au
bout d'un moment ça perd du sens donc
qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire par
rapport à cette situation mon deuxième
ma deuxième question
concerne les aesh il y a un véritable
problème vous parlez à juste titre d'une
école inclusive mais il faut que ça ne
reste pas un slogan il faut qu'il y ait
des moyens des moyens humains et des
moyens financiers or les aesh sont en
nombre insuffisants et là encore on les
rencontre dans nos départements elles
n'ont pas la formation suffisante elles
sont très demandeuses et elles ont des
horaires qui sont mon collègue l'a dit
plus que haché or il y avait eu un
engagement dans le programme du
président Emmanuel Macron concernant la
contractualisation des aesh à hauteur de
35 heures donc est-ce que vous avancez
sur ces questions là et enfin ma
dernière question c'est concernant la
situation des aidants la stratégie
nationale agir pour les aidants s'achève
en 2022 donc il reste de nombreux points
à améliorer pour une meilleure prise en
compte des aidants notamment pour
préserver leur santé lutter contre
l'isolement social et la précarité
développer l'offre de relais et
améliorer aussi la conciliation vie
personnelle vie familiale vie
professionnelle et donc quel projet vous
comptez mettre en oeuvre pour
aider pour améliorer la situation de ces
aidants je vous remercie Elisabeth
Doisneau ensuite monsieur le ministre
répondra et ensuite nous aurons
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre merci d'avoir présenté votre
feuille de route les chantiers ne
manquent pas mais j'aurais envie de vous
dire c'est un conseil si vous n'avez pas
envie d'avoir besoin d'un casque de
protection il va falloir adapter la
méthode alors comment adapter la méthode
je voudrais me rapporter tout simplement
à celle qui a été celle du Ségur suivi
du Ségur 2 de la Forcade 1 la Forcade 2
et je dois vous dire que comme beaucoup
de parlementaires je continue d'être
arrosé de courrier de professionnels
dans le domaine du médico-social ou du
social qui se demandent quand est-ce
qu'ils pourront bénéficier d'une
revalorisation de leur salaire tout
simplement pour dire que évidemment que
c'était super d'augmenter les salaires
dans ces domaines là et ce du sanitaire
avant en tout premier lieu à l'hôpital
public mais c'est la méthode qui a fait
des fausses c'est à dire qu'il aurait
fallu annoncer
le calendrier des revalorisations et
surtout dire que pour les mêmes métiers
on n'allait pas mettre en concurrence
suivant qu'on était dans un tel lieu de
travail ou dans tel autre lieu ou qu'on
exerçait de sous telle statut ou sous
telle autre et ça c'est vraiment
important parce que ça crée beaucoup de
frustrations beaucoup de sentiments
d'injustice alors surtout changer votre
méthode enfin pas vous mais le
gouvernement parce que très franchement
on continue je vous assure et vous sans
doute au ministère pareil donc c'est un
petit conseil que je vous donne parce
qu'il faudrait concilier cette société
qui est vraiment très très en difficulté
aujourd'hui on le voit bien moi j'ai
deux petites questions à vous poser mais
en fait c'est des propositions de
travail parce que sur la personne âgée
on voit que le secteur de l'accueil
familial est en difficulté on a de plus
en plus de mal à recruter dans les
départements pourquoi parce que ces
professionnels en fait ne sont pas
suffisamment rémunérés et que il n'y a
pas eu une revalorisation de ce métier
je pense qu'il y a un petit travail un
petit un petit chantier nouveau à à
mettre en oeuvre ensuite travailler
aussi sur la difficulté qu'on certaines
assistantes maternelles lorsqu'elles ne
sont pas payées par leurs employeurs et
d'ailleurs il y a eu beaucoup
d'interventions de celle-ci
dans nos permanences parce que quand on
n'est pas payé par l'un de ses
employeurs et bien ça met en difficulté
en précarité une profession dont on a
extrêmement besoin aujourd'hui c'est
très compliqué d'avoir des indemnités
pour justement remplacer le salaire qui
est impayé donc il faudrait vraiment
regarder ça et puis le dernier point
c'est sur le PLFSS vous avez indiqué que
deux heures supplémentaires seront
proposés pour justement sortir de la
précarité ces métiers de
l'accompagnement au domicile je voudrais
simplement qu'on fasse très très
attention à ce que comment quand on a
augmenté justement les salaires aussi de
ces aides à domicile ce qui était fort
bien le problème c'est que on a reculé
le nombre d'heures sur les plans d'aide
souvent et donc finalement les familles
et les personnes en particulier se sont
retrouvées avec moins d'heures
d'attention des
professionnels qui étaient mieux payés
mais ça a eu en fait une conséquence
donc faudrait pas que ces deux heures
supplémentaires soient aussi là employés
pour voilà en tout cas que c'est des
conséquences négatives et d'ailleurs il
faudrait aussi nous préciser
comment avec les départements vous
comptez financer cette mesure merci
monsieur le ministre
voilà donc monsieur le ministre je vous
laisse répondre à cette première salle
de question
très bien Monsieur yakovelli Merci
d'avoir souligné l'ambition des mesures
qui sont portées par par le gouvernement
dans ce PLFSS notamment à l'adresse des
familles monoparentales
l'impact est clair comme je vous ai dit
le l'objectif projeté c'est de faire
reculer de plus de points le taux de
pauvreté de ces familles
monoparentales donc l'impact sera
très clair de permettre aussi à toutes
ces femmes de pouvoir bien ne pas avoir
à choisir entre la vie la vie maternelle
et la vie professionnelle et de pouvoir
reprendre un travail on vous transmettra
si vous le souhaitez tous les quatre
types qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a produit
mais vraiment j'ai un cas type là d'une
mère célibataire qui gagne 1300 euros de
revenus par mois qui
à je pense une petite erreur
qui a 1300 euros de revenus par mois qui
a deux enfants quelle place chez une
assistante maternelle pendant 30 heures
par mois avec ce nouveau avec cette
réforme du CMG de se complément libre
choix du mode de garde cette maman
bénéficiera d'une aide de 108 euros par
mois alors qu'elles n'ont bénéficiaient
pas précédemment donc c'est voilà et
pour pour les autres ce sera des
réductions de charge sur
et des gains sur
la prestation qu'elle devait payer pour
les modes de garde individuels et donc
ça va ça aussi en fonction de du revenu
puisque l'objectif sera aussi de
linéariser en fait
sera de linéariser le le le
barème là où on a aujourd'hui des effets
de seuil qui sont extrêmement fort du
début à la fin de la de la de la colonne
des parents concernés on fera attention
aussi dans cette réforme à tous les cas
à typique c'est à dire ça comme ça mais
voilà en France situation de handicap ou
plus complexe à accompagner ou à garder
dans cette réforme et on fera également
en sorte que il y ait le moins de
perdants possible dans dans cette
réforme
le nombre de familles concernés ça sera
par la réforme du du CMG c'est environ
840 000 familles
voilà sur la question des numéros
d'urgence on va traiter ce sujet dans le
cadre de la stratégie lutte contre la
maltraitance donc ce sera plutôt côté
Charlotte cobel qui est chargé de la
protection de l'enfance qui portera ce
chantier je trouve que ouais mais moi
mon avis il est personnel sur ce sujet
là pour avoir été là aussi de l'autre
côté je pense que on a un vrai enjeu
quand même de simplification de des
numéros d'urgence de façon générale
en France et on sait aujourd'hui faire
des des aiguillages et des routages en
fonction de la nature des appels mais je
sais que c'est un sujet sensible voilà
mais plus on ira vers la simplification
me semble-t-il mieux ce sera si on veut
être efficace et puis enfin la question
de la des revalorisations du secteur
médico-social
effectivement il y a un certain nombre
de départements aujourd'hui qui ne
jouent pas le jeu les choses nous sont
remontées
concernant le dernier accord il date de
juin suite à la conférence des métiers
de du 18 février généralement
organisé on organise un comité des
financeurs le 10 octobre prochain où le
11 octobre prochain je ne sais plus avec
les départements justement pour regarder
si chacun a tenu les engagements qu'il
avait pris à ce moment là côté état
comme côté département côté état on doit
regarder notamment sur les compensations
liées à l'avenant 43 qui concerne les
aides à domicile par exemple ce qu'on
prenait en charge 50% de des
augmentations et donc on va s'assurer
que les financements étaient suffisants
pour compenser c'est 50% et puis de
façon plus générale on va avoir une
discussion dans ce cas de dans le cadre
de ce comité pour revoir la relation
entre l'État et les départements dans le
financement de de ces politiques
publiques qui aujourd'hui sont quand
même assez complexes font l'objet
notamment de 15 canaux de concours entre
la CNSA et les départements donc
l'objectif c'est aussi de travailler
alors simplification
monsieur chasseur vous m'avez interrogé
sur le manque d'Ash sur leur statut
voilà je vous dis ce que je dis ils ont
effectivement beaucoup augmenté on va
travailler ça fait partie de la feuille
de route de travailler sur le statut des
aesh notamment pour leur permettre
d'avoir une répondre à l'autre question
sur les conditions de travail de ces
aesh de de pouvoir leur offrir des temps
des temps complets en CDI de pouvoir
aussi travailler sur les ruptures de
parcours entre
le temps scolaire et le temps
périscolaire avec des vraies questions
techniques parce que les on peut vouloir
assurer l'accompagnement d'un enfant
pendant toute la journée mais aussi
veiller aux conditions de travail des
personnes qui vont l'accompagner donc ça
peut poser d'autres problèmes en termes
de droits sociales notamment et donc
c'est tout ce qu'on est en train de
regarder dans dans l'application un
objectif et bien celui-ci
je vous confirme que nous tiendrons nous
tiendrons le cap des 50 000 recrutements
en EHPAD qui sont quand même importants
ça fait quand même un peu plus que ça
que c'est plutôt six ou 7 postes par par
EHPAD notre objectif enfin voilà notre
problème aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
l'attractivité des métiers et notre
capacité à former recruter des
professionnels dans dans les
établissements néanmoins effectivement à
l'avenir il nous faudra une
programmation des finances publiques qui
intègre aussi la montée en charge de et
de cette liée à cette transition
démographique vous l'avez dit pour cette
année c'est un milliard et demi d'euros
qu'on injecte dans la politique
autonomie donc
plutôt conforme avec les projections qui
avaient été faites notamment dans le
cadre du rapport du rapport Libeau
l'année prochaine la branche bénéficiera
d'une d'un morceau de CSG
complémentaires de 0,15 points qui
devrait lui rapporter plus de 2
milliards d'euros donc qui permettra là
aussi de d'investir durablement sur le
sur ce sujet et puis ça n'épuise pas la
question de l'accompagnement de nos
ambitions à la hauteur de la transition
démographique et on réfléchira de partie
des choses qu'on va discuter aussi je
pense dans le cadre du CNR sur sur le
financement à d'autres canaux il y avait
des propositions notamment qui avait été
faites sur la mobilisation de
financement privé aussi qui sont des
questions qui doivent être je pense mis
sur la table
monsieur Assani concernant l'outre-mer
on va travailler avec le ministre de
l'Outre-mer à la déclinaison de cette
feuille de route pour les territoires
ultramarins qui connaissent quand même
des grandes spécificités d'ailleurs
chaque territoire a sa spécificité on
traitera pas la question de la même
façon à Mayotte comme Martinique il y a
quand même des points communs sur voilà
des des problématiques sociales qui sont
sans doute plus criantes taux de côté de
chômage qui est plus fort une transition
démographique aussi qui est beaucoup
plus accélérée voilà le la Martinique
sera dans 15 ans le département le plus
le plus âgé de France et donc voilà avec
aussi des retards en termes d'équipement
médico-sociaux avec vous vous savez bien
aussi des questions plus culturelles
liées à l'accompagnement justement du
vieillissement du handicap etc qu'il
faut donc des approches qui soient très
adaptées à chacun des territoires
ultramarins donc c'est bien dans c'est
bien dans mon dans ma feuille de route
que de l'adapter à ces territoires
madame Cohen donc j'ai bien entendu que
vous craignez que le projet de loi grand
âge en tout cas la question du Bien
Vieillir soit une arlésienne et n'arrive
jamais voilà comme je vous l'ai dit ma
feuille de route là aussi est très
claire avec cette temporalité que j'ai
décrite tout sans me connaître
évidemment la question de l'urgence du
moment et on accompagne l'ensemble des
opérateurs sur les questions d'urgence
liées au recrutement liés à l'inflation
voilà mais pas dire que rien n'a été
fait je rappelle quand même que le Ségur
de la santé je commençais d'ailleurs à
répondre à la question de Madame
douanado mais le Ségur de la santé c'est
quand même 12 milliards d'euros
d'investissement sur l'autonomie c'est 3
milliards et demi d'euros en année
pleine juste pour les salaires donc
c'est quand même quelque chose de un
effort qui est qui est considérable
c'est un impact c'est 15% d'augmentation
pour une infirmière diplômée d'état 16%
je crois pour pour une aide-soignante
donc c'est quand même
significatif c'est clair que en une fois
on rattrapera pas un retard un retard de
de de
rémunération il faut qu'on inscrive
cette dynamique dans le temps et qui
doit être soutenable aussi pour pour les
finances publiques donc ça c'est ça
c'est aussi un sujet et comme j'ai dit
aussi la question salariale n'épuise pas
la question de l'attractivité des
métiers qui est beaucoup plus large que
ça et qui doit être travaillé de façon
transversale et globale et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on l'a remis comme
une des priorités dans le cadre des
discussions au CNR sur les h pardon sur
la reconnaissance aussi importante c'est
que je crois que il faut aussi qu'on
apprenne à parler de façon plus positive
de ces métiers si il ressent la réalité
de ces métiers reconnaître aussi que
c'est des métiers qui ont du sens qui
ont de l'impact et porter un regard
aussi sociétal sur ces métiers qui
soient beaucoup plus positif parce que
si on en parle qu'en disant c'est dur
c'est mal payé c'est maltraitant c'est
négatif on donne pas non plus envie je
pense aux jeunes au moins jeunes de
s'engager dans ces métiers donc il y a
un vrai sujet aussi sur la valorisation
de ces métiers c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on a financé et qu'on continue de
financer sa forme de campagne de
communication autour des métiers parce
que je crois que c'est aussi un élément
qui est extrêmement important et je
reviens pas sur tous les dispositifs
aussi de de formation développement de
l'apprentissage en train de regarder
aussi dans les parcours
dans les lycées professionnels etc pour
avoir des filières qui débouchent aussi
sur sur ces métiers les aidants je vais
pas détaillé mais c'est aussi un la
stratégie aidant arrive à son terme et
on va retravailler une stratégie aidant
ambitieuse dans dans les mois qui
viennent et puis madame douanot j'ai un
peu répondu à votre question mais là
pour avoir vécu de l'autre côté de la
barrière effectivement la méthode c'est
dure je peux vous confirmer que c'est
pas la bonne méthode qu'elle a créé
beaucoup de tension dans les
établissements que à la montré surtout
qu'on dit l'incapacité notre incapacité
collective à piloter des politiques qui
sont très complexes parce que elle
dépendent de canaux de financement de
très différents que l'État a pas
forcément une vision trans la salle en
fait aussi de tous les opérateurs qui
constituent l'écosystème en fait social
et médico-social et donc c'est vraiment
enfin pour moi c'est vraiment une
gouvernance qu'il faut remettre en place
qui soit complètement transversal quand
on prend des décisions salariales pour
des postes qui sont financés enfin des
postes d'intérêt général des missions
d'intérêt général qui sont financées par
de l'argent public on est cette approche
globale et pas seulement parce que là
c'est lourd de la santé il a commencé
par l'hôpital public on a ensuite élargi
ou médico-social et puis ensuite plus
loin on est allé sur les métiers donc
après le soin sur les métiers de
l'accompagnement et puis bah voilà et
aujourd'hui les revendications c'est
celle essentiellement des personnels
administratifs et techniques des
établissements donc moi j'étais un peu
ferme sur le sujet en disant qu'il y
aurait pas 183 euros pour ces pour ces
personnels en tout cas qu'il fallait pas
les attendre du côté de l'État j'ai
renvoyé non pas en disant qu'il les
méritait pas parce que c'est des
personnes qui concourent grandement au
fonctionnement de ces établissements qui
d'ailleurs en général sont très les
fonctions dans les établissements donc
ils ont un rôle qui est qui est précieux
néanmoins j'ai renvoyé aussi à la
responsabilité des employeurs à
responsabilité aussi des collectivités
parce que le Ségur de la santé dans son
approche qui répondait à une urgence à
une situation de reconnaissance dans un
moment difficile pour notre pays à
quelque part
dévoiler le notre fonctionnement
collectif donc l'idée c'est de repartir
et de revenir un système qui soit
beaucoup plus
durable et sain et de le renvoyer à des
négociations salariales normales dans
ces dans ces dans ces établissements qui
peuvent être financés par les canaux les
canaux habituels et pour ce qui concerne
le privé non lucratif moi j'ai prendre
beaucoup d'espoir dans la création de la
Convention collective unique étendue de
branche qui doit justement permettre de
redonner du sens au cadre conventionnel
qui porte en fait ces activités ces
métiers dans le privé dans lucratif
on va essayer de il faut les accompagner
là aussi il faut mettre une gouvernance
en place comment
bah ça met du temps mais je pense que
l'État peut aujourd'hui mettre la
pression l'état des départements parce
que je pense qu'il faut qu'on se qu'on a
un pilotage aussi économique de ces
négociations c'est-à-dire qu'on les
laisse pas négocier dans leur coin et
qu'ensuite on leur dit ça coûte trop
cher et on le financera pas donc il y a
un sujet aussi là de gouvernance et de
portage une question qui à mon sens et
aussi importante d'embarquer le domicile
dans dans cette dynamique là parce que
la concurrence elle se joue aujourd'hui
sur les territoires où vous vivez tous
entre le domicile et le médico-social ou
l'hôpital et ça c'est c'est juste pas
c'est juste pas possible
[Musique]
voilà et sur les sur les questions sur
les assistants maternelles etc j'ai pris
les j'ai pris les points on les a bien
dans le on les a bien dans le dans le
SCOP
voilà j'ai répondu aussi sur le
financement des départements je crois
pas si j'ai oublié une question que que
vous m'aviez posé oui sur les plans
d'aide pardon sur les plans d'aide sur
les canaux donc là aussi ça passe par
les tuyaux les tuyaux CNSA c'est-à-dire
que aujourd'hui la CNSA elle finance pas
seulement les plans là pas la PCH à
l'intervient aussi dans l'aide à
domicile via le complément le complément
qualité
via je l'ai dit tout à l'heure la
revalorisation salariale de l'avenant 43
et puis ça fera peut-être le canal aussi
pour financer les deux heures
supplémentaires en tout cas on sera
vigilant est-ce que ça augmente
effectivement le plan d'aide en temps
horaire donc il y a des sujets
techniques il faut faire sauter les les
plafonds notamment de ces plans d'aide
mais tout ça est à voir et à négocier
avec les départements puisque ça a été
annoncé et pas encore travaillé avec les
collectivités donc je veux pas trop
m'avancer pour ne pas trop empiéter sur
les discussions que nous aurons avec les
départements
alors je signe guides ensuite Corinne
Ferret Victor jasmin René Paul Savary
Corinne Lambert
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais parler des transports quand
vous avez un jeune enfant handicapé et
qui est en maison d'accueil le transport
est remboursé à 100% quand cet enfant
devient adulte non seulement qu'il faut
qu'il change de maison d'accueil mais en
plus de ça il ne trouve pas toujours un
accueil dans son département ce qui fait
qu'il change très souvent de
départements et là le remboursement
n'est plus d'actualité généralement il y
a un forfait de 200 euros à peu près
selon les départements et ce sont les
aidants du coup qui prennent en charge
les allers-retours je connais une
famille qui fait aujourd'hui tous les
week-ends 380 km pour aller chercher son
enfant handicapé parce que les 200 euros
pensez bien que comment dire ça le
forfait ne couvre pas le les
allers-retours donc aujourd'hui moi je
pense qu'il faut quand même revoir cette
histoire de transport il est pas normal
que un enfant qui change de département
en plus pas couvrir le les
allers-retours
certains d'ailleurs moi j'irai pas
abandonne mais ne vont pas rechercher du
coup l'enfant parce que ça fait trop
trop de kilomètres et là pour parler de
ce de ce couple là c'est un couple qui
est vieillissant et aujourd'hui ils sont
épuisés rien que dans les transports
pour faire des allers-retours donc je
voulais vraiment vous soulevez ce
problème là il devait y avoir un réel
travail sur les transports qui n'a
toujours pas été fait je veux savoir où
s'en était merci
Corinne fait rien qui va poser des
questions de Monique Lubin merci madame
le Président Monsieur le Ministre oui
effectivement je vais parler à la place
de ma collègue Monique Lubin qui n'a pu
rester jusqu'à maintenant mais mon
intervention et en même temps question
je m'y associe pleinement je veux
revenir vous l'avez dit mais je vais
revenir sur la loi grand âge vous avez
dit que cette loi appelle débat et
suscite débat vous avez dit qu'avant
d'initier cette loi grand âge il fallait
d'abord s'entendre sur le contenu mais
je pense nous pensons que nous avons
maintenant une idée assez précise des
besoins les choses ont été dites
également par ma collègue Laurence Cohen
je ma question est peut-être un peu
audacieuse mais avez-vous conscience de
l'exaspération qui est en train de
prendre le pas sur l'attente dans les
territoires dans les familles cette
louange tu l'as qualifié dans les yen je
peux reprendre ce mot Laurence depuis
5 ans voire plus de 5 ans sous précédent
quinquennat cette loi était annoncée
donc elle a commencé à être attendu
c'est pas très français ce que je veux
dire mais elle était annoncée on nous
disait année après année oui oui on va
en faire une grande joie parce que c'est
un véritable sujet sociétal vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure Laurence la préciser
c'est comment on accompagne les
personnes vieillissantes les personnes
âgées que nous serons demain je ne vous
souhaite tous et en plus grand nombre et
comment notre société demain et bien
intègre cette population alors ça
concerne les personnels ça concerne les
structures d'accueil ça concerne les
familles les aidants il y a un
véritablement une attente très forte ça
concerne aussi les élus qui est dans
leur commune connaissent ces personnes
âgées et trouvent des solutions imagine
des solutions pour leur permettre des
accueils des accompagnements des
hébergements comme cela un certain
nombre de choses ont été faites la
cinquième branche a même été créée donc
on attend toujours cette grande loi mais
pas simplement au détour de PLF ou de
PLFSS annoncé des financements ou du
Ségur vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
pour des revalorisation de salaire non
c'est véritablement comme cela était
annoncé parce que c'était vraiment le le
bon niveau on va dire la bonne prise de
conscience c'est véritablement d'une
grande loi de nous avons besoin
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
je voudrais suivre votre attention sur
la situation des structures associatives
qui prennent en charge les personnes en
situation de handicap et
particulièrement ceux qui sont et qui
ont des troubles autistiques donc qui
sont vieillissantes donc il y a de vrais
sujets pour leur prise en charge mais
particulièrement pour l'aide aux
associations parce qu'elles ont des
budgets contraints on leur demande de
plus en plus de mettre en place des 6
pommes des contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens ce qu'ils font mais on voit
qu'ils sont en difficulté en difficulté
pour avoir des personnels des personnes
qualifiées en difficulté également pour
recouvrir justement l'ensemble des
demandes alors je voudrais savoir ce que
vous comptez faire là j'ai entendu la
question que vous avez apporté à mon
collègue de Mayotte concernant les
outre-mer mais je crois que là il y a de
vrais sujets concernant la prise en
charge des personnes en situation de
handicap et
aussi à ce qui vient d'être dit
également par Madame ma collègue guidez
parce que le problème de transport se
pose également chez nous et il y a eu
des questions
relatives à cette problématique
récemment traitée avec la sécurité
sociale mais il y a bon des mesures qui
se réprissent notamment pour les TPM
mais je ne sais pas si vous êtes au
courant de cette situation mais
situation du transport pour les
personnes en situation de handicap mais
là bon s'il s'agit de voir davantage
avec vous je suis preneur parce que ça
pose encore des problèmes je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre on a déjà eu
l'occasion d'échanger sur sur le terrain
parce que
l'origine marnaise de Monsieur combe est
tout à fait intéresse bien entendu et je
me permets de vous dire je me permets de
vous dire Monsieur le Ministre attention
à travers toutes ces annonces que ne les
départements n'est pas l'impression que
vous fassiez de la politique sur leur
dos ça reprend les interventions qui ont
été faites deux exemples à travers les
deux heures de convivialité et l'appât
il faut savoir que les départements qui
gèrent la pas ont une dotation mais que
les dépenses sont bien sûr beaucoup plus
importantes surtout au fil des années
que les recettes et que déjà l'APA à
domicile coûte plus cher que la pas en
hébergement et en conséquence même la
négociation sur les heures à 22 heures
ou 23 euros elle a con l'augmentation du
coût de l'heure à une diminution des
heures sur le territoire donc c'est tout
cela qu'il faut rentrer qui doit rentrer
en ligne de compte pour pouvoir
effectivement améliorer ce dispositif et
deuxième exemple c'est à travers le RSA
parce que le la solidarité à la source
me paraît tout à fait intéressante
notamment pour les non recours mais
aujourd'hui on a fait un rapport sur le
Sénat sur le recouvrement notamment par
les urssafs des cotisations je peux vous
dire que le système n'est pas d'une
fiabilité redoutable pour calculer
l'ensemble des revenus et les données
nominatifs qui sont nécessaires pour
cela font aujourd'hui on risquerait de
générer plus d'indus qu'autre chose
pourquoi parce que il faut avoir des
données nominatives et qu'aujourd'hui
l'URSSAF notamment travaille davantage
sur des données agrégées en conséquence
non seulement faut prendre en compte les
revenus éventuellement du travail pour
ces bénéficiaires de RSA mais également
des revenus de la solidarité et ça
devient d'une complexité dans le calcul
qui mérite d'être pris en compte et là
aussi si on va vers ce système il me
paraît important de jouer sur les droits
et les devoirs je voulais dire vous
partagez j'en suis sûr ça il y a des
devoirs
en contrepartie des droits que on peut
avoir c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à
unir la société et non pas à la divisé
et ça coûtera forcément plus cher et en
conséquence ça va pénaliser là aussi les
finances du département moi je rappelle
simplement
j'ai géré mon département pendant 15 ans
42 millions de recettes à l'époque pour
le RSA 90 millions de dépenses et c'est
100 millions maintenant de dépenses il y
a toujours que 42 millions de recettes
pour les bénéficiaires de RSA donc si on
en met encore davantage j'ai une
asphyxie complète des départements donc
faut vraiment prendre ça en compte pour
faire en sorte qu'il soit associé à
votre politique et non pas qui se
retrouvent dans le côté
rétif par rapport à l'évolution des
choses voilà merci en tout cas de
prendre en compte ma remarque alors
Laurence Rossignol ensuite Corinne
Imbert alors
monsieur le ministre d'abord de deux
choses très positives vous avez annoncé
que la SF serait augmenté de 50% des le
budget 2023 c'est vraiment une très
bonne nouvelle c'est nécessaire les
associations de femmes familles
monoparentales le demandaient et la
prolongation du CMG jusqu'à la fin de la
onzième de la 12e année jusqu'à l'âge de
12 ans est aussi une excellente chose
puisque les questions de garde d'enfants
sont un vrai pépaisse lourdement sur les
familles monoparentales donc franchement
mon plein soutien sur ces deux mesures
profité c'est pas souvent et
et donc
voilà non mais j'ai même voilà plus que
vous êtes très bien parti je vous
suggère de réfléchir à la
décongivalisation de la location de
soutien familiale je vous inviterai à
regarder une PPL qui avait été discuté
au Sénat malheureusement pas adopté sur
la suspension de l'allocation de soutien
familiale en cas de reprise de nouvelles
relations amoureuses par la mère c'est
plus souvent le cas et qui est une
disposition pénalisante pour la remise
en couple des femmes et des familles
monoparentales je voulais revenir sur
votre engagement sur les 200 000 places
d'accueil mode de garde
c'est très ambitieux vraiment on ne peut
que soutenir l'ambition mais j'ai pas
gagné les moyens
dans le quinquennat précédent
l'engagement était beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus modeste qui était 30 000
et il n'a pas été atteint donc si on
veut atteindre 200 000 il va falloir
faire beaucoup beaucoup plus que dans le
quinquennat précédent et on évalue je
prends deux instituts à Montaigne et
Terra Nova qui sont pas
soupçonnables ni l'un ni l'autre de
mauvaise volonté
évalue à entre 1,6 et 2 milliards
d'euros par an
l'augmentait 200000 de nouvelles places
de crèches c'est une grosse somme qui je
crois ne figure pas au budget 2023 donc
déjà ça reporte un petit peu le début
des ambitions et ensuite on sait quand
même que depuis quelques années les
classes de crèches qui ont été créés le
sont essentiellement par des structures
à but privé lucratif
on se demande toujours comment là où les
années n'arrivent pas les autres
arrivent à sortir des bénéfices en fin
de temps en temps on a des réponses mais
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
ce qu'on a connu sur le Private bucratif
dans d'autres domaines du médico-social
pourrait un jour être le sujet sur les
crèches et puis je vous avais une petite
phrase à un moment donné en disant qu'il
y avait une grande réflexion sur le
service public de la petite enfance avec
l'hypothèse l'idée de réfléchir à une
compétence obligatoire des communes en
la matière la raison pour laquelle on
construit pas on
autant de base de crèches qu'on veut on
voudrait c'est que on peut aider les
communes à l'investissement le problème
c'est le fonctionnement c'est ça qui
pèse donc quand je dis 1,6 à 2 milliards
d'euros
pour 200000 passes de crèche on voit
bien qu'il s'agit plus l'existant plus
l'existant d'un transfert de charge
énorme sur l'école des communes énormes
sur les communes et que ce transfert de
charge il peut pas se faire comme ça
bref je suis je soutiens l'idée d'un
service public enfance l'histoire du
droit opposable une place de crèche est
formidable aussi je suis juste un peu
perplexe sur les moyens qui vont être
mis en place pour atteindre au moins la
moitié des objectifs
alors Corinne Humbert ensuite Annie le
héros et on arrêtait les questions de
façon comme Monsieur le Ministre oui
merci Madame présente monsieur le
ministre c'est juste un tout petit peu
voilà excuse-moi excuse-moi c'est mieux
quand on peut se voir oui alors mon
intervention est rejoint les sujets
évoqués par Elisabeth Doisneau et René
Paul Savary parce que je crois que le
fait qu'on était soit en C1 conseiller
départemental soit encore conseiller
départemental en fonction évidemment les
politiques que vous portez bien sont
représentent le cœur de métier des
conseils départementaux et évidemment
les mesures proposées ont un impact
direct
la aujourd'hui les départements et
notamment les directions de l'autonomie
qui préparent le budget primitif pour
2023 prennent en compte notamment pour
fixer
l'évolution du taux pour les
établissements prennent en côte
l'inflation prennent en compte l'impact
du Ségur près d'un compte l'impact de
l'avenant 43 on la pression des oubliés
des Ségur avec des revendications pour
lequel il y aura pas de compensation etc
et évidemment quand on fait le total ça
se traduit par des millions d'euros y
compris la compensation par par l'État
par la CNSA donc évidemment la même
attention que que mes collègues sur sur
ces sujets là parce que vous évoquez les
départements qui ne joueraient pas le
jeu il y a peut-être demain des
départements qui ne pourront pas jouer
le jeu donc vraiment et et sur les deux
heures que que vous
présentez dans l'article 34 à du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
on est entre nous même s'il y a il y a
une c'est diffusée mais quand même
est-ce que c'est une façon de compenser
justement la perte d'heures liée à
l'augmentation du tarif pour des
bénéficiaires de la paix qui sont
maximum du plan d'aide et on se le dit
ou alors est-ce que ça sera comme c'est
écrit dans le texte pour permettre de
prévenir la perte d'autonomie de repérer
des fragilités de bâtir du lien social
et est-ce que de fait compte tenu de
cette rédaction ça pourrait être exclu
pour les bénéficiaires j'irai 1 et Gire
deux voilà c'était une précision qui
serait intéressante à avoir et puis je
voulais savoir parce que au début de vos
propos vous avez prononcé le mot magique
la co-construction
qui était aussi très employée par votre
prédécesseur qui quand elle évoquait le
projet de loi grand âge et autonomie
disait clairement quand l'État mettra un
euro on demandera au département de
mettre un euro est-ce que vous êtes sur
cette même logique s'il vous plaît je
vous remercie
excusez-moi je réponds je vous réponds
très vite donc il y a bien un groupe de
travail qui avait été mis en place par
Sophie Cluzel et qui doit rendre ses
conclusions là et donc c'est un des
sujets qui sera pris en compte là aussi
dans le dans le cadre par le CNCPH par
le CIH et dans le cadre de la CNH donc
pour pour pouvoir aboutir mais il y a
effectivement un gros gros sujet j'avais
été alerté dès mon arrivée sur le sujet
des transports voilà merci à vous et
pour terminer annuler
un travail dans le cadre de la mission
d'information sur le contrôle des EHPAD
Bernard bonne et Michel meunier qui ne
pouvait pas être là ce soir je voulais
savoir attirer votre attention sur ces
conclusions et savoir comment vous
envisagez de
[Musique]
la question va déjà été posée par
Philippe mouillé mais peut-être que vous
n'étiez pas arrivé
monsieur le ministre monsieur une
réponse courte
j'essaie de répondre à l'ensemble donc
j'ai répondu sur sur les transports
l'intervention de Madame Ferré
ouais je pense y avoir répondu quand
même longuement tout au long de tout au
long de l'audition on a bien conscience
de l'attente que suscite que le sujet
cette attente qu'on prolonge elle se
fait pas au mépris des travaux qui ont
pu être conduits par l'ensemble des
parlementaires notamment il y a
énormément de rapports qui ont été
produits effectivement qui apportent un
certain nombre de réponses d'ailleurs
dont un certain nombre d'entre elles ont
d'ores et déjà été inscrites inscrite
dans la loi mais là la volonté encore
une fois c'est vraiment de porter le
sujet de façon sociétale de pouvoir
inclure dans ce débat plus largement
les citoyens on regarde de l'enjeu qui
est celui de la place du des seniors des
aînés dans la société et du
vieillissement et de pouvoir se donner
encore un temps de concertation avec
avec les citoyens le cas échéant pour
apporter d'autres éléments et puis
surtout pour prioriser et planifier la
mise en oeuvre de ces de évolution de
ces politiques publiques donc je ne
méconnais pas la tente et la pression
qui est qui est forte voilà j'essaye de
selon la temporalité que j'ai indiqué
j'essaie d'y apporter des d'y apporter
des réponses par ailleurs il y a
je vais y revenir en répondant à
Monsieur Savary mais des questions qui
tiennent aussi au financement et à la
programmation qu'on doit faire pour
pouvoir assurer ce financement
concernant la question de
de Madame jasmin j'ai bien entendu et je
connais bien la situation du monde
associatif et des gestionnaires
d'établissements notamment dans le dans
le secteur du handicap on essaye avec ce
PLFSS de répondre à des besoins
immédiats liés à la fois à
l'attractivité des métiers et à l'impact
de l'inflation puisqu'on a prévu dès
2022 donc dans la partie
finance rectificative 440 millions
d'euros de crédit supplémentaires qui
seront délégués aux AR pour soutenir les
acteurs médico-sociaux il y a quand même
la question j'ai annoncé pour les EHPAD
le gel des tarifs sur l'énergie on est
en train de regarder pour faire la même
chose du côté du côté du handicap donc
j'ai pas encore de réponse donc je peux
pas l'annoncer mais en tout cas on
travaille sur ce sujet là et on
reconduira des crédits exceptionnels en
2023 pour 670 millions d'euros pour
soutenir les opérateurs du secteur de
l'autonomie et je l'ai dit régulièrement
enfin on sera très attentif à
l'évolution de la situation et si
d'aventure il y avait besoin de
compléter ces soutiens on regardera ce
qui ce qui est possible de faire en
cours de en cours d'exercice comme on
l'a fait cette année déjà par deux fois
monsieur Savary
je suis complètement d'accord avec avec
votre analyse et votre votre regard sur
les risques les risques il faut il faut
vraiment en tant que Marne on se
comprend
il faut vraiment que on anticipe ces
risques et c'est vrai qu'il y a des
annonces qui ont été faites c'est un peu
le décalage et donc là moi je me suis
engagé auprès de auprès de Monsieur
Sauvadet et de l'Assemblée des
départements de France à construire une
nouvelle méthode aussi de travail donc
on va maintenant reprendre discussion on
va commencer avec le comité des
financeurs qui sera réuni dans quelques
jours pour les sujets
urgents et puis ensuite pour aborder ces
questions là la relation entre l'État et
les départements et qu'avant d'inscrire
des mesures en tout cas de prendre des
décisions structurelles pour l'avenir on
arrive à trouver les bons canaux de les
bons canaux de financement il y a une
projection il y a déjà dans la
trajectoire des finances publiques une
inscription des crédits des crédits de
l'État pour
compenser les coûts que engendreraient
la mise en place de la solidarité à la
source et notamment dans la lutte contre
le non recours déjà commencé à
construire cette cette trajectoire pour
la question de la part oui je pense
qu'il y a un sujet de dynamique du côté
de la branche autonomie qu'on peut pas
nier et là j'ai dit voilà que il fallait
aussi qu'on qu'on trouve d'autres canaux
de financement dit pourquoi pas regarder
aussi du côté des financements privés de
la contribution des familles aussi d'une
façon ou d'une autre et puis d'autres
d'autres ressources le cas échéant en
fonction des projections qu'on va qu'on
va faire puisque je sais bien
qu'aujourd'hui le financement des plans
se fait
via plutôt via les moyens ou qui sont
aujourd'hui octroyés à la CNSA plutôt
qu'aux besoins et au dépenses réelles
des conseils départementaux voilà mon
souhait c'est vraiment de pouvoir nous
inscrire dans un contrat de confiance et
puis de travailler ensemble et prendre
des décisions quand on aura trouvé les
bons canaux aussi de de financement et
sur la philosophie RSA on est d'accord
enfin je me suis beaucoup exprimée
là-dessus sur l'articulation sociale
travail qu'il fallait pas opposer et au
contraire je pense qu'aujourd'hui et ça
sera l'objectif de toutes nos politiques
publiques je pense que Olivier du soft
vous a parlé de France travail je
travaille avec lui sur ce sujet mais le
plan de lutte contre la pauvreté aussi
visera à beaucoup mieux accompagner les
bénéficiaires du RSA ou les personnes
très exclues vers une reprise d'activité
donc ça sera vraiment notre politique
sera vraiment tournée vers ce vers ça ce
que vous appelez devoir puisque je pense
qu'on est tous choqué aussi de voir
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un taux de chômage
et un taux de un nombre de bénéficiaires
du RSA qui est très élevé dans un marché
du travail qui est quand même
extrêmement tendu on a beaucoup parlé
d'attractivité des métiers c'est que
notre système fonctionne quand même pas
très bien de façon de façon globale
merci Madame rossignol pour vous votre
soutien et vos compliments dont vous
partiez sur sur les familles
monoparentales je pense que voilà
c'était vraiment c'est une mesure qui
était forte enfin qui est forte et qui
est attendu j'ai bien entendu le le
décalage perçu entre l'ambition affichée
des 200000 places d'accueil alors pas
que des places en crèche mais vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui il va vous savez très
bien que 60% aujourd'hui des modes
d'accueil c'est des assistantes
maternelles et des modes de garde à
domicile
que dans la trajectoire de la branche
famille on a prévu quand même des
crédits je dis on va renégocier aussi la
cause et donc ça va être le moment aussi
où on va poser les moyens les moyens
nécessaires pour ce pour ce
développement il faut qu'on discute là
aussi avec les collectivités puisque
j'ai dit que l'option était en fait
c'est pas une question de moyens il y a
un sujet aussi de de d'incitation on va
dire des des différents acteurs pour le
développement de l'offre sur les
territoires
et je
en dehors de confier cette
responsabilité à une collectivité
notamment bloc communal j'ai du mal à
voir comment on va vraiment pouvoir
atteindre ces objectifs si on veut pas
faire reposer le développement de
l'offre d'accueil uniquement sur le
secteur privé comme ça peut être le cas
aujourd'hui dans certains territoires et
je pense comme vous que c'est absolument
pas à souhaitable donc voilà on peut y
se voilà développer une offre qui soit
diversifiée offrir le choix aux familles
il y a certains territoires où il y a
que ça et ça pose des problèmes
d'égalité d'accès de qualité aussi
d'accompagnement et de sécurité pour
pour les enfants enfin je dis très
clairement donc c'est pas c'est pas
forcément souhaitable donc c'est un peu
tôt on est encore un peu en amont de la
discussion parce que encore une fois il
faut que on discute avec la knaf et avec
les collectivités
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que j'aurais pas répondu comme
comme question oui vos questions pardon
madame Imbert sur le la question des
départements et
voilà j'ai un petit peu j'ai un petit
peu répondu sur le
non sur les deux heures c'est vraiment
de trouver un mécanisme pour que ce soit
vraiment deux heures en plus quel que
soit alors je crois qu'on a je crois
qu'on a pour l'instant limité
c'est bien pour c'est bien pour tout le
monde et ensuite sur sur la cour
construction mais ça aussi ça fait
partie des discussions qu'on doit avoir
avec les avec les départements il faut
qu'on faut qu'on mette tout sur la table
et que on est une discussion qui soit
renouvelée parce que là ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pas très simple en fait
c'est ça crée des tensions qui sont pas
également cette dichotomie entre les
jours de A4 et puis les 5 6 parce que
c'est là qu'on fait la prévention quand
même au niveau des 5 6 il y avait moins
des choses à faire pour éviter la
prévention qui remonte en dépendance
sont pas concernés pourtant là il y a
des actions de prévention nettement
intéressantes à un moment où c'est
l'énergie à la prévention
la question alors madame le héros oui
non mais on va vous la donner
à s'attendre de proposition du rapport
dans le dans le dans le PLFSS et
notamment un renforcement de des mesures
de contrôle à la suite de toutes celles
qui avaient déjà été prise
au début de au début de l'année ou que
je peux que je peux vous lister la
soumission à l'accord préalable des
autorités de tarification de la
possibilité pour un groupe de signer un
ces pommes puisque apparemment il y
avait des groupes qui signaient voilà et
ensuite ça posait des questions sur
l'utilisation des des financements du
sébum de limiter dans le temps l'usage
des excédents sur les financements
publics avant afin qu'ils soient
effectivement dépensé détendre le
pouvoir des ARS donc en l'espèce sur le
siège d'un groupe gérant plusieurs EHPAD
pour pouvoir les contrôler donc c'est ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
l'autorisation de recours à des
astreintes journalière lorsqu'un
organisme contrôlait de transmet pas les
documents demandés donc vraiment de
pouvoir obliger
et contraindre les établissements
concernés à transmettre les les
documents une obligation aussi de
transmission d'une comptabilité
analytique à tester retraçant des flux
financiers entre les établissements
médico-sociaux et le groupe des
sanctions et des astreintes
qui seront affectés à la CNSA dès lors
qu'elle relève de dès lors que les ESMS
concernés relève de l'objectif global de
de dépenses et puis enfin la
récupération des indus par la CNSA
donner le le cette possibilité à la CNSA
pour lorsqu'une autorité de contrôle
tarification
effectuera un contrôle au sein d'un ESMS
géré ou sous contrôle d'un d'un groupe
et se rendre compte qu'une entité une
des entités du groupe a bénéficié de
Somme injustifiées de la part de cette
SMS et donc là la CNSA pourra les
demander en lien avec la question hors
péage et dit que l'État serait très
ferme dans les discussions effectivement
il conteste une partie des 56 millions
d'euros
réclamés pour 30 millions d'euros je
crois d'entre eux et donc les
discussions sont en cours avec la CNSA
mais j'ai demandé à ce que notre
position soit très ferme on regarde la
situation et du comportement du groupe
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
une première audition on se fait une
audition riche et fournie et nous
souhaitons une bonne soirée on vous dit
à bientôt